from groceries to basic necessities gas
cars home sales everything is costing
more and that cost is really starting to
affect those trying to find an
affordable place to live according to
rent.com the average rent for a
one-bedroom apartment now about
15-hundred dollars joe mueller is live
near spring mountain in polaris with the
struggle some people are facing joe
well people who have lived in las vegas
for some time now are used to paying
less in rent compared to other cities
around the country well during the
pandemic rental prices have just gone up
and that is for some people to make some
tough decisions
without paying 12.66 patrice davis says
her rent went up two hundred dollars at
these northeast valley apartments the
jobs and the rent has not had enough she
is going to try to look for a cheaper
place than 1300 dollars she may not have
much luck i'm going to start looking
probably next month to move somewhere
else like to find you know a cheaper
place that you know i better afford
according to rent.com the average rent
for a one bedroom in the area is fifteen
hundred dollars that is up from one
thousand one hundred and sixty seven
dollars from february of 2021.
properties that are the most sought
after are getting applications within
hours of being put on the market real
estate expert christian morgan says with
low inventory rentals aren't going fast
and with more people moving to the las
vegas area he doesn't see it slowing
down anytime soon so i definitely see
the rental market continuing to increase
in value and the prices are just going
to go up the drastic increases are
forcing some to make tough decisions it
was just too much i left california for
that particular reason that's why i came
to vegas ernest ryan says rent went up
hundreds of dollars for him at the end
of the year pay didn't go up
but rent did
he decided to leave for pueblo colorado
last month for a bigger rental home on
more lands i can't do it it was either
colorado or texas
out here live ernest there said he
wanted to buy a home in las vegas
eventually but with the way the real
estate market is going for resale homes
even he says he wouldn't have much luck
here so that also influenced his
decision to leave nevada reporting live
joe moller live local now